foreign
is with us in Portland Oregon hi Aurora
how are you
hi I'm good thank you God how can we
help today
um so I the last couple of weeks I've
been kind of
um you know been watching all of your
guys's stuff on YouTube I actually found
you guys on Tick Tock and
um yeah and I've just been kind of you
know the last couple of months I've been
really trying to
um get settled and pee after and just
seems like any way that I try I I can't
and I always refer back to living
paycheck to paycheck and I just I'm kind
of over it I I don't feel like I'm
content where like where I am in life
and so I feel like part of that is just
having so much debt and you know having
kids to take care of and wanting to plan
for them and I don't I don't know like
where to start I don't know what to do
anymore boy I like you you're in a
really really good place thank you for
calling and I like you just because you
mentioned to Dave that you found us
through Tick Tock Dave loves Tick Tock
I'm not sure if that speaks poorly of
you or of me but one of the two okay
I love it yeah um and it's actually my
birthday today so I'm like you know what
happy birthday glad you got through
thank you like if it's not today then I
don't know what day is yeah it's a great
day to call so walk us through the debt
how much debt do you have
well um I paid up I paid off quite a bit
now but um I have about 21 000 I would
say between my partner and I
um that we still need to pay off and
most of it is credit card debt so so you
said you paid it off uh tell us about
the debt you paid off
um so that you know while when they were
giving the uh unemployment during Covey
it took months for me to get my like
checks um because everything was so
behind and when I finally got like my
claim it wasn't that much um I paid off
my car I was like this is one thing that
I need to you know get rid of because
God forbid I you know can't work anymore
I can't find another job but I need that
you know I need that to get around yeah
I just want to stop and applaud you for
that because the fact that you're
already you know Wheels in Motion you
paid off your car that's that's great
yeah so what's your income yeah
um between my partner and I unique about
5500. okay let me stop a second are you
married
no we're not we live together okay all
right so legally you are too you have a
roommate
and for the handling from the handling
of your money that's the way the law is
going to look at it
right yeah so um you pay off your
partner's debt you get zero credit for
that with the law
okay so you're combining your money with
your roommate is a bad idea
yeah because of where you stand legally
so how much the 21 000 is that all in
your name
no okay what is in your name
ten thousand okay what is that on
uh that is credit card debt okay and um
good and you paid off your car way to go
and what do you make
uh I make
a month is about twenty two hundred okay
all right good for you and how old are
you
I'm 28. and what do you do for a living
I am an elementary school secretary
oh well thank you for your service
thanks for what you do for the kiddos
okay so if you've been watching the
videos are you familiar with the term
gazelle intense
oh I hope and not yet
Dave can you do your Dave exclamation
point
the best oh okay so here's the thing
what we have figured out is is that
personal finance is 80 Behavior it's 20
head knowledge and so for for your
partner
with their money we'll tell them to do
exactly the same thing you're doing but
not combined but not combined okay so
we'll have the same result that you're
looking for but when you combine them
you leave yourself open to other
problems that we don't want to get into
okay like who who bought the mustard or
whatever all that garbage right so
um now uh so the what we if personal
finance is 80 behavior that means when I
get control of me
I have the best possible control and of
My outcome with my money the more
intense I get
the deeper I sacrifice and the deeper I
sacrifice the more money goes towards
cleaning up the mess and the quicker I
get stabilized
and moving towards wealth
so in other words if you goof around
with this stuff and sort of kinda do it
and you still go out to eat and you
still go on vacation and you still buy a
bunch of crap that hasn't got anything
to do with the goal of getting rid of
these credit cards it's going to take
twice as long and you're going to be
half as likely to ever even do it
right and if you get so intense that
it's like yeah if you get so intense
that it's like you're gonna die if you
don't get rid of this credit card debt
in five months then you're gonna work
six jobs and you're gonna eat ramen
noodles and you're not gonna do nothing
but work and get out of debt because
that's intense and sacrifice and that's
what we mean by gazelle intense like the
gazelle running from the cheetah doesn't
want to be eaten and doesn't want to be
killed they're they're running for their
freaking lives this is not an
intellectual discussion this is very
visceral it's bone marrow you are going
for it right
and that's that's there's something that
happens in 30 years of me doing this
when people get that level of pissed off
that they're willing to cut everything
that their friends think they've lost
their minds they think you've joined a
cult then you're on track so you need to
get out the credit cards when you get
off the phone and chop them all up in
the little bitty pieces every one of
them and you need to get on a written
budget and you need to get another job
or six
and you're not going out to eat you're
not going to see the inside of a
restaurant unless you're working there
and you're not going on vacation all
you're doing is getting out of debt
because how's it going to feel when you
don't have any debt it's going to feel
really good how's it going to feel when
you don't have any debt have ten
thousand dollars in the bank it's going
to feel really good we call that
Financial Peace
yes but you're gonna pay a price to get
there you're going to live like no one
else
so later you can live and give like no
one else okay that's what Christine is
talking about
yeah and I'm super encouraged when you
split things out you've got ten thousand
dollars you've got twenty two hundred
dollars a month and you're 28 years old
you can work six jobs you can make the
sacrifices you can do this quickly
you're working in elementary school it's
over 3 30. you've got time to do three
more jobs I mean you really do I mean
you can go make some serious money and
there's people hiring out there like
crazy right now big time
so and you have to do this forever you
just do it for a short period of time
it's a Sprint
you just bust it for a short period of
time
hang on Aurora we like you we're going
to put you through our class called
Financial Peace University we're going
to pay for it watch those classes hold
on I'm going to pay for you to have a
membership you watch every one of them
and do every single thing we said to do
and you'll be wealthy
up to you